public schools are not doing well since
the early 70s we've more than doubled
per pupil spending an inflation-adjusted
dollars without increasing test scores
for high school seniors seems like a
problem that's just too big to fix yet
one of the best ideas to radically
improve k through 12 education in
America is so small that it can fit into
the backpack of the tiniest first grader
it's called weighted student formula or
backpack funding here's how backpack
funding works instead of giving a set
amount of dollars to a school based on
the number of students in a given
district each student is given a certain
amount of funding that follows them to
whatever public school they enroll in
students with special needs get extra
dollars that follow them and under the
best version of backpack funding
educators have complete flexibility to
use the money as they see fit on more
teachers on facilities programs or
whatever they think will help their
students succeed with such great
educational freedom comes great
responsibility to schools either perform
or parents will take their children and
their dollars elsewhere back tech
funding focuses attention and resources
exactly where they should be on the
students and it gives principals
teachers and parents the chance to find
out what particular program will work
best for each suit well over a dozen
major school districts including ones in
houston newer at San Francisco and
Boston have implemented versions of it
with solid outstanding results Houston
for instance has increased its
graduation rates by more than ten
percent after giving more control to
students and principals kids love to
personalize the backpacks they bring to
school backpack funding lets them their
parents and their teachers do the same
for education for reason TV i'm nicholas
lee